time
the greatest star
I am
that's breakout Broadway star Julie
benko performing the hit song I'm the
greatest star from funny girl in New
York City recently until a few months
ago Banco was mostly unknown to those
outside the theater world but for the
last month or did she's been killing it
she's been starring in funny girl and
making the role of Fanny Bryce all her
own Jamie wax spoke with Banco about her
meteoric rise Jamie good morning again
sounds like you're a fan I am a fan and
she is a meteor you're right Gail good
morning in 1964 a relative unknown
someone you might have heard of called
Barbara I think it's Streisand shot to
stardom after playing Fanny Bryce now
more than five decades later it seems
history may be repeating itself after a
lot of Backstage drama this time with a
new star hello Julie benko
here
I am
here is Julie benko on the big stage
playing the iconic role of funny girls
Fanny Bryce
[Music]
but no one knows but people do know it
now and Banco is being noticed not just
by Future critics and audiences this is
where the stage manager follows the show
or on her popular Tick Tock account but
also the streets of New York City
we were just seconds into a walk in the
Theater District when someone spotted
her that gentleman just said it's funny
girl
just a few minutes later banco's
childhood neighbors walked up oh my God
tonight yeah we can't wait how did you
find out this was what you were gonna do
I always loved theater I always loved
singing nobody thought I had any special
talent to speak of I really got involved
in high school my High School drama club
[Music]
over the years Banco made a quiet name
for herself on stage 2009
booking Regional shows National tours
and roles on Broadway this was
originally my locker she honed her craft
here at New York University's Tisch
School of the Arts I find myself on
stage and backstage every day using the
skills that I really developed here
[Music]
the greatest stuff hi friends we
arranged for one of her former
professors Deb Lapidus to surprise her
Lapidus helped benko learn I'm the
greatest star
[Music]
did you see something in her when she
was your student well yeah because it
doesn't take a genius to figure that out
the role of Fanny Bryce was benko's Big
Break first is a standby for Beanie
feldstein then when feldstein decided to
take her last bow a month early Banco
stepped up for a full eight shows a week
this incredible opportunity for you has
come amidst one of the most dramatic
stories of the year in Broadway I've
learned to tune out a lot of the noise
because it's not helpful and I try to
remember that I'm doing this because I
love it people who need people
the role of Fanny Bryce was of course
first played by the legendary Barbra
Streisand
when we visited Banco backstage she was
rehearsing the song people bringing it
down a half step to where Streisand
originally sang it
[Music]
foreign our world
she paved the way in a lot of ways it's
one of the reasons this is the first
Revival ever of this this great musical
is because of the shadow of Barbra
Streisand do you feel that every night
[Music]
I don't fully feel that shadow of
Barbara I'm trying to bring myself I'm
trying to sing the role in a way that's
healthy in my instrument I'm not I'm not
trying to imitate the story of Fanny
Bryce is one of Triumph and heartbreak
and the Allure for benko the real Fannie
herself an unapologetically Jewish woman
from Brooklyn in the early 20th century
Fannie was a Jewish comic and she
specifically created characters that
were Jewish so it's very meaningful when
I called my mom to say I got the role
the first thing she said was if your
grandmother was still alive she would be
so proud someone who is also very proud
of bangko her husband jazz pianist and
composer Jason Yeager
[Music]
last week Banco and Jaeger came out with
a new album among the songs they
recorded p
Eep
funny girls people I'm just so grateful
that the whole world now is discovering
who Julie benko is and what she's
capable of how does that make you feel
Julie oh my man I love him so
funny girl both starts and ends with
Fanny looking in a mirror hello gorgeous
but by the end she is transformed an
unknown who is turned into a star quite
like benko herself you get to go out and
do what you love and people share it
with you
what more could you ask for
[Music]
you know this is a reminder of what a
lovely platform this is to tell stories
to people I am so proud that we got to
tell her story starting September 6th
former gleece darlia Michelle will take
over as Fanny but Julie will be her
alternate she will fill in and stars
Fanny every Thursday night she told us
she's looking forward to getting to
continue to play this beloved role and
she is really wonderful and she's got a
beautiful voice oh she's she's uh she's
got the comic chops she's got the acting
chops and she can sing it and you know
she's been caught up in a lot of unfair
to me I think women get treated very
badly in a lot of businesses obviously
but in show business as well and and I
think I have been lucky to interview and
meet beanie feldstein and Leah Michelle
they are both incredible talents yes but
she has been caught up in the midst of
this drama unfairly and she she deserves
this moment I'm really happy no fault of
her own through no fault of her own no I
can tell Jamie you are a big fan I am I
am raving about her yeah makes me want
to see her good let's be there until
September yes which is this is September
I mean it's a yeah she said she's there
Jamie thank you very much